[Música]
Bienvenidos a un nuevo episodio de
boleto de vuelta que en esta ocasión nos
lleva a Japón este país vivió una
historia digna de una película de espías
o de una novela en plena guerra fría
este hecho generó un trauma para decenas
de familias japonesas en los años 70 y
80 Corea del Norte llevó a cabo una
campaña de secuestros en los países que
llamarían enemigos y uno de sus vecinos
cercanos Japón era su objetivo principal
Este programa de secuestros creado por
altos mandos del Estado
stalinista tenía probablemente como
objetivo entrenar a Los espías
norcoreanos enseñarles el idioma y las
costumbres japonesas pero no fue hasta
2002 cuando la dictadura de pyongyang
reconoció oficialmente algunos de los
secuestros en una conversación con el
Primer Ministro japonés Aunque Corea del
Norte acabó reconociendo 13 secuestros e
incluso envió a algunos de los japoneses
de regreso a su país las autoridades
niponas han pruebas de 17 secuestros
pero en realidad podría haber muchos más
Quizás cientos el caso de megumi yokota
es especialmente emblemático esta joven
fue secuestrada hace 45 años en Mi gata
la ciudad más grande de la costa
japonesa frente a Corea del Norte Este
ha sido un hecho que ha afectado
profundamente a la sociedad de este país
pero la familia de megumi no pierde la
esperanza Esta es la historia
[Música]
tacuya bellocota lleva 45 años buscando
a su hermana megumi
desapareció una noche de noviembre de
1977 cuando volvía a casa después de la
escuela
[Música]
mi mamá nos llevó a mi hermano y a mí y
buscamos en el barrio con una linterna
Así es como todo empezó
sentí que algo Andaba mal
en ese momento solo tenía 9 años
Así que terminé quedándome dormido
mi mamá también pensaba que me gumi iba
a volver y no estaba muy preocupada
pero a la mañana siguiente no había
vuelto y por la noche Tampoco
la situación continuó así
en mi 54 años de vida Esa ha sido la
semana más duración
[Música]
megumi un nombre y un rostro que
marcaron a Japón
imágenes de una niña alegre y rodeada de
sus hermanos gemelos apasionados por las
ciencias naturales
lo único que le queda a su hermano para
recordarla es este álbum familiar
[Música]
amigo
Estas son las fotos de antes de la
desaparición las fotos de una familia
Feliz como cualquier otra familia me
recuerdan nuestra felicidad Me gustaría
volver a esa época
después de la desaparición nos pareció
que era un tabú preguntarles a nuestros
padres por mi hermana y también nos
pareció que hacían todo lo posible para
mantener la apariencia de ser una
familia normal fue duro especialmente
para mis padres nos reíamos menos
hablábamos menos
el misterio era total y las hipótesis
múltiples se había fugado se había
ahogado había sido víctima de un crimen
la policía japonesa no descartó ninguna
de estas posibilidades para su hermano
megumi Sigue estando ahí en algún lugar
como un fantasma en su vida
cuando llueve o nieva me pregunto si
está bien pienso en ella todos los días
poco sangre
cuando veo a las mujeres en la calle
teniendo una vida familiar normal con
sus hijos pienso en la vida feliz que me
gummy podría haber tenido aquí
poco a poco surgió una pista sobre la
desaparición de megumi
en la década de 1970 en plena guerra
fría apenas 1000 kilómetros separaban a
Japón Aliado de Estados Unidos de la
comunista Corea del Norte
[Música]
piong acababa de lanzar un programa de
secuestros a nivel mundial en Corea del
Sur Europa y en las costas del vecino
Japón los agentes norcoreanos
secuestraron a docenas quizás cientos de
personas para entrenar a sus espías en
culturas extranjeras
entre las primeras víctimas estaba
megumi yokota quien vivía en Mi gata una
gran ciudad portuaria e Industrial del
norte de Japón
la foto de megumi fue tomada entre este
árbol y ese
periodista siempre ha vivido en Mi gata
a principios de la década del 2000
comenzó su carrera investigando la
desaparición de la colegiala y el
misterio todavía le obsesionan
[Música]
estamos frente a la escuela donde megumi
yokota estudiaba hasta que fue
secuestrada el 15 de noviembre de 1977
ahora es mediodía pero en aquella época
se acercaba el invierno y Ella salió del
lugar Poco después de las seis de la
tarde cuando ya había oscurecido
takashi ha caminado docenas de veces
tras los pasos de megumi Hasta el lugar
de su secuestro estamos a 500 metros de
la escuela megumi iba camino a casa
después de una clase de bádminton estaba
sola la casa de los yokota estaba cerca
no había iluminación Así que estaba
completamente oscuro megumi yokota fue
presuntamente secuestrada en esta
intersección aquí el perro rastreador de
la policía dio vueltas y perdió el olor
de megumi
una testigo me contó lo que escuchó
entre las 6:30 de las 7 de la tarde
los gritos parecían gritos de auxilio
era la voz débil de una niña
si en ese momento ya hubiera prestado
más atención
si no hubiera ignorado los gritos ni
cerrado la ventana las cosas Podrían
haber sido diferentes
la policía buscó megumi en los bosques
en los ríos en las playas pero no había
Rastros de ella
de hecho su secuestradores la ataron o
la metieron en una bolsa y se la
llevaron en un auto a la costa
la subieron a un barco hacia Corea del
Norte desde una playa como ésta
Cuando era pequeño había un ambiente
extraño en Mi gata
era la guerra fría y el mar de Japón era
un lugar tenso
historiador a los niños que paseaban por
las playas se les decía a menudo que
corrían peligro de ser secuestrados por
marineros extranjeros
es un recuerdo terrible
en esa época pensaba que podría haberme
pasado a mí muchos niños pensaban lo
mismo
en 2002 se produjo un momento histórico
por primera vez un Primer Ministro
japonés visitó pyongyang como gesto de
buena voluntad Kim Jong y le reconoció
secuestro de megumi y de otros 12
japoneses todo el archipiélago estaba
conmocionado
[Música]
poco se sabe la vida de megumi yokota en
Corea del Norte
Esta es una de las pocas fotos enviadas
por pyong se piensa que allí vivió bajo
constante vigilancia enseñándoles a Los
espías la lengua y la cultura japonesas
en la actualidad Aunque Corea del Norte
aseguró Haber puesto fin a los
secuestros algunos de los habitantes de
Mi gata no creen que sea así
les digo mis hijos que nunca regresen
solos a casa que estén siempre
acompañados
crees que esos secuestros pueden volver
a ocurrir
es muy posible
nunca se sabe
Muchas gracias
evitó salir solo especialmente por la
noche o al amanecer
como los secuestros ocurrieron cerca nos
preocupamos
en Tokio el caso tomó un giro político y
el tiempo corre para las familias de los
desaparecidos
el papá de megumi yokota falleció en
2020 sin volver a ver a su hija y a sus
86 años es su madre quien está perdiendo
la paciencia
nos encontramos con ella y con el
hermano de megumi en Tokio
lo mismo
han pasado más de 40 años desde que
ocurrió
Incluso si solo hubiera dos o tres
ciudadanos secuestrados de esa manera un
país se indignaría y Haría todo lo
posible para recuperarlos Aunque tuviera
que intervenir por la fuerza
todavía no sabemos lo que ocurrió
realmente tengo mucha rabia dentro de mí
todos los años los giocotas se reúnen en
público con las familias de los
secuestrados y los políticos que apoyan
su causa
el objetivo es presionar al gobierno y
exigirle una actuación contundente
ese día asiste el mismo Primer Ministro
los secuestrados y sus familias están
envejeciendo
Así que no hay tiempo que perder para
resolver este asunto
conútame para lograrlo estoy decidido a
reunirme con el líder Kim Jong un hincho
todo Sin condiciones
pero las palabras del Primer Ministro
dejan un sabor amargo Cuántas veces han
escuchado estas familias las mismas
promesas entre el público hay
principalmente cientos de familiares de
víctimas no reconocidas oficialmente en
Japón hay 17 secuestrados pero podría
haber hasta 900
arriba arriba
[Música]
esta mujer vestida con kimono está
convencida de que pyongyang está detrás
de la desaparición de su hermana en el
centro de Tokio hace 50 años
mi hermana debería tener 82 años
en Correa del Norte
dependiendo de si El caso es reconocido
o no la policía no despliega los mismos
recursos de búsqueda y rescate son
lo que a mí respetaba el gobierno no ha
hecho nada
en 2002 Corea del Norte devolvió A Japón
a cinco de sus ciudadanos
y el día de su regreso caso giro arachi
estaba en la plataforma para conocerlos
ahí se están bajando del avión sus
familias y partidarios estaban ahí para
darles la bienvenida
Cuando llegamos a la ciudad natal de uno
de los retornados todos los empleados de
la alcaldía se habían reunido para
darles una bienvenida calurosa a todo el
mundo decía es maravilloso que hayan
vuelto pero no sabíamos Cómo se sentían
realmente
habían tenido hijos en Corea del Norte y
los habían dejado allá por lo que
psicológicamente no podían ser críticos
en el régimen así que no se atrevían a
decir mucho
desde entonces Corea del Norte afirma
que todos los demás japoneses
secuestrados como megumi murieron
para el país más hermético del mundo el
caso está cerrado pero este activista
quiere creer que algunos secuestrados
siguen vivos
para empezar Esta es la información
sobre los secuestrados japoneses
les habla desde esta estación de radio
en Tokio tres horas diarias de programas
grabados en japonés y coreano
que pronto Fueron interferidos por
Esto es lo que se oye allí
[Música]
Este es el sonido de la interferencia
utilizada para bloquear nuestros
mensajes
en 17 años el señor araki nunca ha
recibido una respuesta no se sabe si
megumi sigue viva o Si alguna vez
recibió estos mensajes
para hacer oír su voz en la escena
mundial Japón cuenta con un poderoso
Aliado
a principios de 2022 por primera vez la
embajada estadounidense en Japón envió a
un representante a los presuntos lugares
donde ocurrieron los secuestros
incluyendo Mi gata
tío la familia yokota fue recibida en la
embajada para hablar del secuestro de
megumi yokota
pero nada me preparo para lo que vi hoy
Estados Unidos se solidariza con las
víctimas y sus familias
estamos con ellos en su sufrimiento y
dolor
el presidente de Estados Unidos Joe
biden Incluso se reunió con familiares
de los secuestrados entre ellos la
familia yokota
Bush Obama Trump los yokotas han hablado
con todos los presidentes
norteamericanos hasta ahora sin
resultados
desde 2019 Corea del Norte rompió todas
las relaciones con Japón
y Mi gata los padres siguen temiendo que
sus hijos no vuelvan a casa después de
la escuela por la noche
megumi yokota la niña perdida de Japón
no abandonado los corazones ni los
pensamientos del país todo Japón Sigue
esperando el regreso de la colegiala 45
años después de su último día de clase
[Música]
Gracias por acompañarnos en esta edición
de boleto de vuelta que en esta
oportunidad nos llevó a Japón reviviendo
la herida abierta de los secuestrados
japoneses por Corea del Norte y
Recordando el simbólico caso de megumi
yokota recuerde que puede Ingresar a
nuestra página web France 24.com para
ver esta emisión y las anteriores Hasta
pronto